There are two tasks for you. First off, to make a new question. Here, we
construct the question, and now we need to set the question text. There's a
method for that. And we need to set the desired answer, and there's a method
for that. Really all you had to do is look up here and imitate how to set up
the first question. In the present question method, we first display the
question. Again, there is a method for that. To find that out, you actually had
to look up the Question class, the method is here. There's no other way to show
that question text than to call display. The code for reading the response was
already given to you. Now, we need to check if it's the correct response.
That's the job of the checkAnswer method that you also had to discover by
looking at the code of the Question class. It gets the user's response and it
returns true of false depending on whether it's correct or not. We were
supposed to print true or false. The simplest way of doing that is to just
print the value of the Boolean variable. But, of course you could also print
true in this branch and false in this branch if you prefer. So if the outcome
is true, we return a score of 1 otherwise a score of 0. Let's just run this
program. So let's see. Who was the inventor of Java? Everyone knows that or
not. And who was the founder of Udacity? Oh, I better get that one right or
I'll get in trouble. Now,
[LAUGH]
I did this one right and at least I got a score of 1. So, now you have an idea
on how the basic question class works. And we're ready to refine that class by
forming sub-classes of it.